borings are crunchy and salty so you get
a crunchy mouthful of cheesy goodness hi
i'm blake and today i'm going to show
you how to make boar eggs four eggs are
a flaky armenian puff pastry these
things are delicious they're perfect
little appetizer or sometimes you can
have them with coffee or tea they make a
nice light lunch but they're also just a
great way to start a meal my dad's
family is arabic assyrian and my mom's
family is english i grew up in nashville
tennessee where nobody knows what an
armenian is so this is something adapted
from something my grandmother would have
made a lot of these recipes are written
down in different church cookbooks these
are two different fillings that we're
doing today they're both cheese and
they're both very savory when you're
making boar eggs especially if you're
making spinach ones you need to really
wring out your spinach and any other
herbs you want to get as much moisture
as you can out of them you don't want
them to steam you don't want them to be
soggy and you also don't want the
mixture to be so pasty that you can't
handle it appropriately we're using
a low moisture high fat koshkoval from
bulgaria sometimes called rodopa
kashuval is typically a sheep cheese
it's actually a whole grouping of
cheeses
so you can use any sort of sheep cheese
that's nice and salty you can also find
it in the grocery store and there's
something called kasari with the sea but
i've seen recipes for people using
munster you can use just a regular feta
you could use something like velbraceo
anything you just need to sort of
balance it out with salt because these
are both really salty cheeses so when
you're working with feeler dough you
want to keep it moist at all times or
else it's going to crack and fall apart
using a ruler to get a consistent size
on your strips will let you have a
perfect triangle shape every time make
sure that the dough stays covered at all
times take a rag or a paper towel get it
wet underneath the sink and wring it out
thoroughly before you put it on top or
else even in 5-10 minutes it will
completely dry out i think growing up it
was a little bit difficult for me to
identify with being armenian in any
sense of that food was one of the ways
that i sort of connected to my parents
and my family's culture being queer in
nashville wasn't always comfortable
and then coming to la i felt like i was
comfortable being queer and then
suddenly presented with being armenian
because of my last name i'd never
really known a lot of armenian people in
nashville and i'd always felt sort of
outside of the heteronormative culture
there and then coming to la once again
felt like i was put outside of another
culture and sort of looking inside of it
i think living between two cultures and
being queer actually very similar and
that you always sort of find yourself on
the outside of mainstream culture
whether you're a queer kid or a mixed
race or have parents from different
cultural backgrounds i think that trying
to find connections wherever you feel
comfortable is a great way to figure
yourself out food was a way for me to
connect with both my parents heritage
and my queer identity but i think it
could be anything for anyone just have
to figure out what it is for you
oh yes
you